[موسيقى]
مساء الخير على حضراتكم حلقه جديده مع
الدكتوره نفين مسعد وبنتكلم على اثار حرب
غزه على دول المنطقه طبعا الحرب طالت
اثارها الكثير جدا من الدول وسواء بنتكلم
على مصر بنتكلم على طبعا لبنان بنتكلم على
الاردن بنتكلم على دول كتيره في العالم
انما احنا النهارده بنتكلم على دول
بعينيها وهنبدا
بالعراق اللي بينقر رويدا رويدا الى دائره
الصراع الواسع اللي اطلقته حرب غزه بدايه
من يوم 7 اكتوبر مساء الخير اولا مع
الدكتوره مساء النور يا استاذ سيد ربنا
يخلي حضرتك تعتقدي ان العراق الاثر
المباشر للحرب غزه على العراق ايه
ا الاثر المباشر هو ا طبعا تزايد اشتباك ا
لبعض الفصائل الحشد الشعبي
ا مع ما يحدث في
غزه خلينا نقول انه طوال الوقت كان في
استهداف للقواعد الامريكيه من بعض الفصائل
وبالذات حركه النجباء وكتائب حزب الله
اللي هم مكونين من مكونات ا
الحشد الشعبي طوال الوقت ده حتى قبل غزه
لكن العمليه كانت بتبقى محدوده وكانت
بتبقى مش عايزه اقول معزوله لكن عايزه
اقول ان مالهاش يعني شعبيه كتير في العراق
ليه لانه العراق راغب في الاستقرار راغب
الا ينجر الى مساله الصراع الايراني
الامريكي احنا كل ده بنتكلم على ما قبل ما
قبل غزه والحقيقه انه ده كان يعني اتجاه
بدا مع حيدر العبادي رئيس الوزراء وبعدين
استكمل مع مصطفى الكاظمي والان مع محمد
شياع السوداني فهذا الاتجاه موجود منذ
سنوات نحن وقيل بالفم الملان يعني من من
كل رؤساء الوزراء نحن نريد ان نلعب دورا
في الحفاظ على استقرار المنطقه لا ان نكون
مصدر من مصادر عدم الاستقرار وده جه بقى
في شكل انفتاح العراق على جواره الاقليمي
العربي بعد ما كان في يعني شبه شبه اعتزال
للعراق من الجانب العربي واحجام بالتالي
من العراق عن يعني الانخراط في المحيط
العربي وده من 2003 ف اصبح هناك انفتاح
اصبح
هناك تاكيد طوال الوقت على الدور العراقي
المحافظ على الاستقرار جاءت حرب غزه وادت
الى انه الفصائل التي كانت طوال الوقت
بتستهدف ا مصالح امريكيه واهداف امريكيه
وكذا وجدت لها
منطقا لتصعيد لتصعيد هذا النشاط وخصوصا ان
احنا بنتكلم على انه لولا الدعم الامريكي
ما كان يمكن ان يكون هناك عدوان استمرار
لهذا العدوان وتصعيد فيه بهذا الشكل
داخلين في الشهر الرابع وهذه الفصائل بقى
اصبحت تستهدف القواعد الامريكيه في داخل
العراق ايضا في داخل سوريا ونحن نعلم انه
الساحتين متداخلتين الى الى حد كبير
الفصائل نشطه في في في الساحتين
فبالتالي جر العراق الى هذا هذا المربع و
مربع ايه بقى مربع الصراع مربع الصراع
مربع الصراع اصبح طرفا فيه يعني اصبح طرفا
فيه يبقى اذا اول نتيجه لان انا عاوز
استاذنك لو في نتائج اخرى بس اسال على
النتيجه الاول ص اذا اول نتيجه لحرب غزه
انه
فصائل الحشد الشعبي اللي كانت بعض فصائل
بعض فصائل الحشد الشعبي اللي كانت راغبه
في استهداف القواعد الامريكيه زادت
شعبيتها وزادت او زادت مشروعيه هجومها على
القواعد الامريكيه داخل العراق وخارج
العراق الامر اللي
بيصطبح وكثير من الشعب العراقي اللي يرغب
في الاستقرار اكثر وعدم المواجهه صح صحيح
انا بس قبل ما نستانف الكلام عن النقطه دي
ونقاط اخرى هل ممكن ندي لان كثير من اللي
بيتابعو مش عارفين الشان العراقي وهو شان
برض مربك بسبب تتابع الاحداث هل ممكن ندي
خريطه كده للقوى الاساسيه بايجاز في
العراق وتوجهاتها المختلفه
ا هي طبعا الخريطه العراقيه شديده شديده
التعقيد وشديده السيوله في الوقت احنا
بنتكلم عن عدد سكان حوالي 40 مليون مثلا
مثلا حوالي في الحدود دي فاحنا عندنا
منذ 2003 ابتدت تتشكل بعد سقوط نظ بعد
سقوط نظام صدام حسين والاحتلال الامريكي
وكذا اصبح عندنا قوه سياسيه
حزبيه مختلفه خالص خريطه حزبيه مختلفه
تماما يعني عندنا قوه حزبيه سنيه وعندنا
قوه حزبيه شيعيه وعندنا قوه حزبيه كرديه
وتحت كل يعني يعني فصيل او او او او معسكر
داخل كل معسكر من هذه المعسكرات مجموعه
بقى من من الا الازاب المختلفه هذه
الاحزاب مش بالضروره كلها يعني على قلب
رجل واحد يعني في داخل المعسكر الشيعي على
سبيل المثال هناك خلافات واحيانا مواجهات
بين التيار الصدري التيار اللي بيقو الشاب
مقتضى الصدر و وعدد انصاره بيقدر بحوالي
700 ال شخص وهم يتميزون
ب الولاء التام الولاء التام
لهذا الزعيم الشاب فاحيانا
بيختلف مع غيره من
فصائل الشيعيه وفي الانتخابات المحافظات
الاخيره هو مثلا قاطع الانتخابات التيار
الصدري قاطع الانتخابات لكن عندنا بقى
يعني فصائل
اخرى دوله القانون تيار الحكمه كل ده في
المعسكر الشيعي لكن اهم القوى في المعسكر
الشيعي التيار الص عندنا التيار ال في
عندنا حاجه دلوقتي اسمها الاطار التنسيقي
الاطار التنسيقي ده
بدون بقى يعني ما اخش في تفاصيل هذا
الاطار التنسيقي نشا
ا نتيجه ا يعني صراع الانتخابات
التشريعيه الاخيره في في العراق التيار
الصدري حصل على 27 مقعد فده جعله اهم قوه
شيعيه لكن ما يقدرش لوحده يشكل الكتله
الاكبر اللي تستطيع ان تسمي رئيس الحكومه
عظيم فبالتالي حاول في البدايه انه يعني
يقتطع بعض العناصر من القوى الشيعيه مثلا
يمد كلام مع او جسور مع تيار الحكمه اللي
هو بتاع السيد عمار الحكيم او مثلا مع
السيد حيدر العبادي انما هو مشكلته
الاساسيه مع نوري الملكي يعني الاول السيد
مقتضى الصدر كان بيحاول يشكل اغلبيه يشكل
اغ فتوجه في البدايه للشيعه ما عفش يشكل
الاغلبيه ابتدى يتوافق مع السنه برده
ويحاول ما عفش المهم انسحب من العمليه
الانتخابيه امر يعني او طلب من نوابه ان
هم ينسحبوا من البرلمان في مواجهه
هذا هذا الحراك من جانب السيد مقتضى الصدر
رات قو الشعيه مختلفه ان تاتل معان في
مواجهته لانه هي شعرت بالخطا هي يعني شعرت
انه هو يريد ان يجعل من نفسه الطرف
المتحدث باسم هذا باسم هذا
هوار الشيعي او الاطار الشيعي فنشا ما
يسمى بالاطار التنسيقي الاطار التنسيقي ده
بقى اللي فيه الحجد الشعبي واللي فيه
الفتح
وفيه دوله القانون وفي طير الحكمه الى
اخره المكونات المختلفه ليست على قلب رجل
واحد لكن زي ما بقول انه في
مواجهه الرغبه في تهميشها او استبعادها او
تقليل دورها على الساحه فهي شكلت هذا
الاطار التنسيقي اذا انا عندي القوى
الشيعيه التيارين الاساسيين فيها في
اللحظه الراهنه هو التيار الصدري والاطار
التنسيقي الذي يضم مجموعه من الاحزاب
هدفها الاساسي الحقيقه هي مواجهه التيار
السائد قبل تكوينها وهو التيار الصدري
يعني احنا عندنا التيار الصدري واحد قوه
واحده انما الاطار التنسيقي مجموعه احزاب
ا شيع عظيمه جدا عظيم جدا وعندي القوى
السنيه ايوه مجموعه من مجموعه من الاحزاب
منها مثلا حزب
التقدم للحلب وسي وهناك احزاب اخرى
والتوافق واشياء من هذا القبيل انما برض
الوجه البارز فيها هو الحلبوسي محمد
الحلبوسي كان رئيسا للبرلمان او لمجلس
النواب حتى وقت قصير ثم اسقطت رئاسته او
استبعد نتيجه قضايا معينه يعني وحتى الان
هذا قضايا معينه دي سر يعني ولا قضايا لا
لا لا لا قضايا انه كان احد ما كانش فساد
انه كان احد النواب هو اختلف اختلف معاه
فنحه واعتبر انه ه هذه التنح غير قانونيه
وبالتالي
اسقطت ر او ازيح من رئاسه البرلمان حتى
الان القوى السنيه لم تتفق على شخص يخل في
الحلبوسي يخل في الحلبوسي ومع انه هذا شان
سني مع الاسف يعني ان احنا بنتكلم على
دوله لكن بنقول هذا يعني رئيس مجلس نواب
بما انه سني فهو شان سني ورئيس الوزار بما
انه شيعي شان شيعي الى اخره لكن طبعا
الشيعه لابد ان يكون لهم دور اساسي في
عمليه الموافقه على من يصل الى هذا المكان
عندنا بعد كده بقى المعسكر الكردي هو نفس
الحكايه في لبنان يعني رئاسه الجمهوريه
شان ماروني مسيحي لكن انا لازم هو يختاره
برض لازم الشيعه لازم السنه يشاركوا في
المساله يعني دي فكره المحاصصه الطائفيه
دي مشكله المحصه او التقسيم الطائفي
للمناصب عندنا بعد كده بقى الاكراد الساحه
الكرديه الاتحاد الوطني الكردستاني
والديمقراطي الكردستاني عندهم برض مشاكل
في ما بينهم في ما بينهم يعني كل قوه كل
طرف من هذه الاطراف عايزه اقول انه بينهم
خلافات داخليه بقدر ما بينهم خلافات بينهم
وبين بعض يعني مثلا الاقليم هم بيسموا
كردستان الاقليم اختصارا عنده مشاكل مع
الحكومه المركزيه فيما يتعلق بالرواتب
و تص رف عائضه النفط وحاجات كتير من هذا
النوع لكن الحزبين نفسهم في ما بينهم خلاف
على تولي المناصب على اداره الاقليم
واشياء من هذا القبيل فدي الصوره العامه
للساحه العراقيه بتنوعاتها المختلف اذا
انا عندي ثلاث قوى رئيسيه سنيه شيعيه
كرديه القوى الشيعيه انا عندي التيار
الصدري وال والاطار التنسيقي اللي بيج
مجموعه من الاحزاب المتباينه
عندي الحزبين الاساسيين الكرديين وعندي
مجموعه احزاب ب يعني في الص الحزب
الاسلامي في السنه يعني الحزب الاسلامي
حزب تقدم اشياء من هذا عظيم جدا الواضح
يعني انه الخلافات البينيه بين كل طائفه
اكثر من الخلافات ما بين الفئات المتباينه
يعني الخلافات الشيعيه مش هقول اكبر لكن
هي قائمه هي موجوده واحيانا يعني الاطراف
دي بتستقوي ببعضها ببعض يعني تيار الصدري
لما اراد ان يواجه القوى الشيعيه المختلفه
كان بينسك مع مثلا الحلبوسي ومع
يعني قوه او طرف اخر ايضا قوي سنيا على
الصعيد العراقي اسمه خميس الخنجر شخصيه
سياسيه بارزه فاحيانا
بيستخدموا يعني بيستخدموا الاطراف الاخرى
في مواجهه بعضهم البعض او نلاقي الحزبين
الكرديين واحد منهم يستخدم مثلا او يلجا
للمركز
لمواجهه الطرف الاخر في يعني هذه خريطه
معقده يعني الخريطه ادي انت وصفتيها بمق
وكانت معقده قبل 7 اكتوبر اي ا لانه هي
معقده لانه في خلاف ما بين الفصائل
الرئيسيه صحيح ثم وده يعني يربك الحسابات
لصانع القرار او رئيس الوزراء العراقي
وبيربي الصراع بين قوى اقليميه كبيره على
ارضه هل تدينا بايجاز شديد اهم القوى اللي
بتلعب دور على الاراضي العراقيه يعني
الولايات المتحده ايران تركيا مش دي القوى
الثلاثه الرئيسيه ولا بالاضافه لدول
الخليج كمان وطبعا عندنا الجماعات بقى
المسلحه بتكلم على قوه خارجيه اه قوه
خارجيه طبعا عندنا ايران عندنا اساسي يعني
ايران الولايات المتحده وعندنا طبعا تركيا
دي القوه دي القوه الاساسيه اللي موجوده
وكل واحد منهم داخل لمصلحه
وطبعا وهذه القوى احيانا بتتسه واحيانا
بتتفق ا فاحنا بنتكلم دي الثلاث قوى الخار
الرئيسيه المؤثره في القرار او في الشان
العراقي يعني في الشان العراقي بالضروره
في القرار العراقي يعني تركيا مالهاش
تاثير على القرار العراقي لكن تركيا
موجوده بحكم وجودها العسكري وبحكم
استهدافها اه هي هي بحكم استهدافها
للاكراد بحكم يعني علاقتهم بحزب العمال
الكردستاني المعارضه الاساسيه الكرديه في
تركيا ف فهي
موجوده ويعني انما تاثيرها على قرار
العراقي لا مش موجود طيب عظيم احنا خدنا
القوه الرئيسيه وخدنا ال الرئيسيه
الداخليه والقوى الخارجيه الرئيسيه حضرتك
اشرت الى ان بتوجد جماعات بقى كلمه جماعات
دي انا تصوري ان هم الحشد الشعبي والحشد
الشعبي اصبح جزء من مؤسسات الدوله انت لما
بتتكلمي على جماعات مسلحه بتشير الى الحجد
الشعبي ولا جماعات اخرى غير الحجد طب في
حاجتين طيب الحاجه الاولانيه لما اكلمت
على الجماعات انا اقصد اقول انه بقايا
داعش اه تنظيم داعش ما ما اختفا هو يعني
ضعف تراجع انزوى لكنه اختفى كم جز ك طبعا
هو الموصل سقطت اه في 2014 فالي عايز
اقوله انه لم لم
يختفي فكريا هو موجود تنظيميا لم يختفي
فكريا ضعف تنظيميا ولكنه لم يختفي والدليل
ان احنا من وقت للتاني بنشوف هجمات له في
هذه المنطقه او تلك فانا اقصد
بالجماعات المسلحه من هذا النوع بالنسبه
للحشد الشعبي ففي مشكله وبرده ده وضع
الحشد الشعبي هيتاثر
بمردود حرب غزه وهقول لحضرتك ازاي الحجد
الشعبي ده نشا ازاي يعني نشا ازاي نشا
بموجب فتوى من ايه الله السيستاني يعني
احد اكبر المراجع الشيعيه في النجف بانه
احنا بصدد
تنظيم
دموي عنيف اللي هو تنظيم ده سقطت الموصل
في قبضته فهبوا ل التطوع في مواجهه
هذا
التنظيم الدموي الجيش عاجز عن ده اجهزه
الامن عاجزه ف يعني يبقى التطور احنا
محتاجين اسناد ما كانش بهذا بس احنا
محتاجين اسناد دعوه للتعبئه الغالبيه كانت
من الشيعه من القوى الشيعيه المختلفه ثم
مجموعه من من السنه ومن من من يعني جزء من
المسيح حين وعرب وغير عرب وتركمان واشياء
من هذا القبيل فاحنا كونا ما يسمى بالحشد
الشعبي الهدف الاساسي هو اسقاط هذا النظام
هذا التنظيم وتحرير
الموصل خلاص تحقق هذا الهدف لم يكن في
حينه احد بيتكلم على الحشد الشعبي سلاحه
او مش سلاحه لان سلاحه كان موجه الى تنظيم
داعش اما وقد وضعت الحرب اوزارها واما وقد
انزوى هذا التنظيم وضعف ابتد السؤال
حوالين لماذا لا يتم ادماج الحشد الشعبي
في الجيش يعني هذا التنظيم ظهر اصبح عندي
تنظيم ومعاه سلاح وبقى عنده قرار ازدواجيه
يعني ازدواجيه في المؤسسه العسك ز الدعم
السريع كده في سور في سوريا السودان في
السودان اسفه وطبعا احنا عندنا في في
العلوم السياسيه احد تعريفات الدوله
الدوله تقوم باحتكار القوه او با باحتكار
السلاح هي ناس دوله ما بتحتك السلاح انها
لازم تحتكر السلاح
تعرفها وعشان انا مش عايزه بس ادخل الساده
المشاهدين في في يعني في اشياء اخرى لكن
الحقيقه السلاح مش مش بس مشكله السلاح مش
بس مشكله حشد شعبي لكن عندنا البيشمركه
مثلا الكرديه ما البيشمركه عندها عندها
سلاح عندنا القبائل مسلحه ا حتى النخاع
يعني فهي في في في مساله سلاح لابد ان
تنظر ان ينظر اليها في عمومها في العراق
لكن لو احنا بنتكلم على مساله الحشد
الشعبي فبن انه ايرت نقطه لماذا لا يتم
ادماج الحشد الشعبي في الجيش
ا يعني رفض هذا رفض هذا المنحى
و ولازال الحشد الشعبي طوال الوقت بيدافع
عن سبب وجوده او حاجته للاستمرار انه
الجيش جيش نظامي لا يستطيع ان ياخود حرب
عصابات ا انما اللي سهل مواجهه داعش ان
احنا عندنا ناس مؤهله انها تدخل في
الاماكن الضيقه في الجبال في اشياء من هذا
القبيل وده نفس منطق بس انا فاهم هو تم
تشريع وجوده يعني هو دلوقتي جزء شرعنته
طبعا تم تمت شرعنته
شرعنه وجود الحشد الشعبي ولكن ليس كجزء من
الجيش هو جزء من القوات المسلحه يجوا
يقولوا لك القوات المسلحه العراقيه بتتكون
من ايه هنقول بتتكون
من من الجيش يعني من الجيش بتتكون من قوات
مكافحه الارهاب اللي هي يعني اه قوه
الخاصه بتكون كمان من الحشد الشعبي الخاصه
ف هي هي جزء من مكونات
الوا المسلحه لكن ماهش جزء من الجيش طب
يعني بمن تاتم باوامر من دي دي بقى نقطه
خلافيه هي المفروض انها بتتمر هي واضح
انها بتحصل على اموالها ورواتبها من
الدوله من الدوله طبعا وهي اه ولكن هنا
بقى
بتيجي القضيه الخلافيه يعني لما ما يكون
رئيس الوزاره بيقول نحن لا نريد ان نشتبك
في حرب دائره اه ثم تاتي بعض فصائل الحشد
الشعبي وتهاجم القواعد الامريكيه في قرب
اربيل او قرب مطار بغداد او في اي مكان
وعين الاسد ال الى اخره لا لما يحدث يحدث
هذا فطبعا يبقى هنا ما فيش اتمار اتمار او
يعني استجابه ل اذا حت على الورق هي جزء
من اجهزه الدوله وهي تحصل على ت بها من
اجهزه الدوله وبتحصل على اسلحتها من من
الدوله او على الاقل باركه الدوله السلاح
اللي كانت بتملكه ومدتها
بالمزيد لكن عند اتخاذ الاوامر هي
بالضروره ليست
بالضروره لا تنصع بالضروره لتوجهات الدوله
يمكن ان تخرج عنها طبعا طبعا طيب ده احنا
كده عندنا دوله براسين طيب احنا عندنا
الحاج الشعبي دي كلمه كبيره ما هي اهم
القوه في الحشد الشعبي اللي بارزه الان
على الساحه مثلا عصائب اهل الحق حركه
النجباء كتائب حزب الله دي دي العناصر
الاساسيه يعني سؤال سريع قبل ما اسال
حضرتك عن لان هم اللي ظاهرين في الوجه
دلوقتي الى اي حد هذه الكتائب او هذه
الجماعات او الفصائل هي ادوات او حلفاء
لايران ا لا هم يعني الحج الشعبي في عمومه
علاقته وثيقه بايران يعني علاقته وثيقه
بايران لكن لكن اللي عاييز اقوله انه برض
في مساله علاقه القوه الاقليميه بالاطراف
الداخليه ما نفترض برده انه في حاله تماهي
تام يعني ما فيش ما فيش حاله تماهي تام ا
بين الاثنين يعني في فتره من من الفترات
يعني انا بتكلم على القوه الشيعيه بشكل
عام في فتره من الفترات القوه الامريكيه
القوات الامريكيه كانت بتؤدي دور ا في حفظ
استقرار العراق بعد 2003 وكان هناك حرص
على وجوده لكن كنا بنلاقي مثلا واحد زي
مقتضى الصدر بيشن بيشن حرب على القوات
الامريكيه او بعض الفصائل الشيعيه الاخرى
بتشن حرب على الوجود الامريكي ف اللي
عايزه اقوله انه هذا التماهي ماهواش موجود
لكن في طبعا فيش تماهي ليه ما هو كان من
ايران من مصلحتها مثلا استقرار الوجود
الامريكي وهم دول خرجوا عن القرار
الامريكي مثلا في بدايه في بدايه احتلال
العراق طبعا كان ب مصلحه ايران انه يستتب
الوضع يعني بعد 2003 احنا احنا اذاء حدث
جلل اسقاط نظام كبير وقوي ومهم زي نظام
صدام حسين
ا يعني ايران مستفيده من من هذا الاستقرار
اللحظي بعد فتره بقى من هذا الاستقرار
اللحظي استنفد غرضه خلاص ايران اصبحت
موجوده ف تغير الوضع انما في مرحله
المرحله الاولى لا طبعا هي كانت حريصه على
استتباب الوضع في في العراق وهو ما خرجت
عنه بعد القوى وهنا بقى اللي احنا بنقوله
يا استاذ سيد فكره انه العلاقه بين امريكا
وايران والعلاقه بين ايران واسرائيل انه
ما هياش طوال الوقت صدام لكن احيانا بتلت
قي المصالح في قضيه من القضايا انا في
تعبير بيعجبني في وصف هذه العلاقه يعني هي
فكره التعبير اللي بالانجليزي يقول عليه
فراني فران صديق وانمي عدو لكن فرمي لاف
هيت ريليشن شيب بس هي مش لاف هيت ريليشن
شيب هي غالب عليها الهيت لكن او حب
الكراهيه علاقه الحب الكراهيه لكن هو مش
حب حتى هو مصلحه هو مصلحه مش حب اه عظيم
طيب نعود الى بقى موضوع الساعه وبايجاز
شديد الانعكاس اه احنا احنا شفنا خريطه
كده خريطه مربكه طبعا يعني ولكن هي الاساس
فيها انه واضح ان الدوله ومركزيتها بتعاني
دلوقتي صانع القرار اللي اللي موجود رئيس
الوزراء متمثله في رئيس الوزراء عنده تحدي
التحدي الاولاني ان انا عاوز احافظ على
استقرار العراق واحميه من التاثير الخارجي
لكن اندلعت
حرب 7 اكتوبر او حرب اكتوبر والحرب على
غزه وفي فصائل جوه العراق بدات تعبر عن
تضامنها مع غزه بضرب القواعد الامريكيه
باعتبار امريكا هي الراعي الاساسي
لاسرائيل
الوضع ايه في العراق ده ممكن السيطره عليه
هل لا يمكن السيطره عليه الوضع ايه طب انا
هقول لحضرتك مجموعه من النقاط كده بدون
ترتيب بس يعني تخص الاجابه واحد انه عندما
بادرت بعض فصائل الحشد الشعبي بمهاجمه
الاهداف الامريكيه القواعد الامريكيه داخل
العراق او حتى داخل سوريا انطلاقا من
العراق دا العراق
ا رئيس الوزاره ادان ده بكل وضوح وقال انه
هذا ليس موقف
الدوله لكن عندما ردت الولايات المتحده
بتنفيذ هجمات داخل العراق وانتهاك السياده
العراقيه بعض بعض هذه الجماعات او
التنظيمات ا يعني وطبعا ومؤخرا باغتيال
احد قيادتهم فطبعا ده ق ادى الى صدور بيان
من رئيس الوزاره شديد اللهجه للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه انه ده في انتهاك
للسياده العراقيه وهذا
يعني لا يجوز ولا ينطبق على علاقه العلاقه
بين ايران بين بين العراق وبين الولايات
المتحده فبدايه هدد كمان في اعتقد يعني
بشكل انه يمكن
ان دي النقطه
الانيه اذا بعد بعد ان كان رئيس الوزاره
يدين هجمات
الفصائل ادان الهجوم الامريكي اثنين نقطه
الوجود الامريكي الولايات المتحده ليها
حوالي 2500 شخص بيقال انهم مستشارين
عسكريين بيقدموا المشوره الى الجيش
الايراني الجيش العراقي طيب هذا الموضوع
محل نقاش طوال الوقت على الساحه العراقيه
طب العراق مستفيد من الوجود الامريكي ده
ولا ولا لا طبعا المساله حملت اوجه
ا من حيث انه هذا الوجود
بيمثل انتهاك لسياده العراق وكذا هو بيمثل
انتهاك ل سياده
العراق هل مش هو مش مش هذا الوجود
بيوازن ادوار قوى اقليميه اخرى زي ايران
اه هو بيوازن فزي ما بقول كده المساله
حملت اوجه فطوال الوقت هذا الموضوع بيصار
وبي داخل بداخل البرلمان الى اخره
لكن زي ما حضرتك كنت اشرت بقى انه اما وان
الولايات المتحده تصرفت على هذا
النحو وهجم اهداف تخص الحشد ورؤوس في
الحجد وكذا فده احيا مجددا فكره اخراج
المستشارين العسكريين بما فيهم يعني اتكلم
عنهم رئيس الوزاره نفسه اللي هو مفروض انه
يعني يعني طبعا كلماته لها لها اثر ولها
وقع ولها مدلول فهو اتكلم على هذه النقطه
وانا اتصور ان دي هتبقى يعني قضيه ساخنه
في الساحه العراقيه النقطه الثالثه المهمه
انه احنا برض كنا بنتكلم في الجزء السابق
او يعني السؤال السابق على مساله سلاح
الحشد وانه الحشد ماهواش مدمج وكذا في ظل
هذا الانتهاك الامريكي
ل السياده العراقيه من الذي سيقول للحشد
الان سلم سلاحك مين اللي هيقول له سلم
ولاح القضيه هتطور يعني او من اللي هيقول
انه ادخل الحشد فيه داخل الجيش مين مين
اللي هيقول لا ليه يعني لا طبعا لانه اللي
هيقول كده لانه انت اضعفت
موقف معارضي الحشد لانه هذا السلاح هو
القادر على اصابه ايلام الولايات المتحده
وربما ارغامها على الخروج من الساحه
العراقيه ف انا اتصور انه ده قوه الحشد مش
اضعفه عاوز اسال حضرتك قبل ما اسال عن
احتمال تاثير
اشتباك اجهزه عراقيه ومنها الحشد الشعبي
مع الامريكان
بسبب حرب غزه وهو ده السؤال الرئيسي انت
كنت سالتك عن القوى الرئيسيه لكن القوى
الرئيسيه دي ايران ايران هي موجوده بشكل
غير مباشر من خلال
دعمن في العراق في العراق هي موجوده بشكل
غير مباشر لا مالهاش قواعد يعني لا لا
مالهاش قواعد اه اه طب موجوده بقوه بس اصد
ما فيش حد يقول هنطرد الايرانيين لان هي
مش موجوده على الارض لكن اللي ممكن يقولوا
نطردهم هم الامريكان او العرا الاتراك
اللي هم بالتعريف يعتبروا م احتلال ولا
تختلف في
هذا محتلين طعا هل
الاحتلال التركي للعراق والهجمات المستمره
احيانا ده سؤال جانبي قبل ما اسال هو بيحظ
بتاييد بعض القوى في العراق يعني في بعض
القوى لانه واضح ان هم يعني انا مره سمعت
من مسؤولين اتراك يقول والله احنا اتكلمنا
مع المسؤولين العراقيين قبل ما نضرب يعني
وانه كلام المسؤولين العراقيين عن ادانه
هجمات لينا في العمق العراقي فضلا انه هو
يعني بيفت قد الى المنطق لان انتم مش
قادرين تمنعوا الهجمات الكرديه علينا لان
احنا كمان مبلغين بغض النظر الكلام ده
دقيق غير دقيق سؤال لحضرتك هل الوجود
التركي والهجمات التركيه على العراق احيا
احيانا بتحض بدعم غير مباشر من من بعض
النخب العراقيه طيب خلينا نقول علشان
الصوره تبقى واضحه قدام الساده المشاهدين
ان احنا بنتكلم
على علاقه تركيا بالعراق فيما ليس له
علاقه بحرب غزه طبعا ده سؤال عارض يعني
طبعا
لما تركيا موجوده بزعم
مواجهه يعني قواعد حزب العمال الكردستاني
وتسل ل الى الاراضي العراقيه ودعمه هناك
وبتقف المواقع التي ترى او المنطلقات التي
ترى انها
بتمثل يعني نقاط ارتكاز او نقاط حركه لحزب
العمال الكردستاني فدي دي القضيه الاساسيه
هو حزب كردي انفصالي كان بيرغب في
الانفصال داخل تركيا هو حزب طبعا هو قوه
المعارضه الاساسيه
ا لتركيا
طيب من وجهه
النظر المباشره او والرد المباشر هل ده
يعني مدان او لا طبعا المفروض انه يكون
مدان لانه ده احتلال انا ما بصنف الاحتلال
انه احتلال او مش احتلال بسبب الدين او مش
الدين هي تركيا دوله محتله وكون ليها
قاعده عسكريه فزي زي الولايه
المتحده يعني الاحتلال هو احتلال في فرق
لان الولايات المتحده حتى الولايات الوحده
مدعوه يعني باتفاق موجود لكن تركيا لا
مافيش هذا الاتفاق يعني لا ما هي طبعا
تركيا برض بتحت بهذه النقطه بالعكس بتقول
انه في ايام صدام حسين كان في اتفاق على
ما يسمى المطارده الساخنه او الهوت برسوت
ان انا ادخل الى داخل الاراضي العراقيه ل
مطارده حزب العمال الكردستاني والعراق
يدخل الاراضي التركيا
لمطار المتمردين الاقراض طب راح صدام حسين
والحكومه بتقول احنا متبرين من تراث صدام
حسين جمله وتفصيلا فهم بيتمسكوا بشيء ليس
له وجود طب الاتفاق ده قايم طب احنا
عايزين نخرج منه مش عارفين يخرجوا منه هو
مستمر فلا ففي اتفاق هنا او زعم بوجود
اتفاق وهنا في وجود اتفاق
طيب الاجابه المباشره او الاولى هي انه
طبعا لا اي اي احتلال لابد ان يكون مدان
لان في انتهاك للسياده وتعدي على السياده
وشيء من هذا القبيل لكن ربما ربما ينظر
الى هذا الوجود العراقي وجود التركي
الوجود اسفل تركي على الاراضي العراقيه
باعتباره كابح
ل الطموحات الكرديه في داخل العراق وطبعا
نتذكر انه في 25 سبتمبر
2017 الحزب الديمقراطي الكردستاني لمسعود
برزاني في هذا الوقت نظم استفتاء على الحق
في تقرير المصير
للشعب الكردي في داخل العراق وطبعا طلعت
الغالبيه مؤيده الانفصال وتك تكوين دوله
كرديه وده دق ناقوس
خطر واضاء نور احمر امام امام الدوله
العراقيه لانه في الحقيقه انه اقليم
كردستان في العراق بيتمتع بمجموعه من
الامتيازات ويمكن بقى ده يبقى وقته تاني
يعني لا علاقه لها بالوضع الفيدرالي في اي
دوله من دول العالم في اي دوله من دول
العالم لكن ورغم ذلك هم عندهم شب مستقله
اه ش يعني من الناحيه العمليه فهو ظم هذا
الاستفتاء وكان نتيجته نعم نريد الانفصال
فربما ينظر الى مساله الوجود التركي على
الاراضي العراقيه وقصف مواقع للاكراد بين
الان والاخر انه هذا هو راضع او كابح
للوجود
ا الطموحات التركيه وبالمناسبه على فكره
برض ايران بتقصف برض مواقع للاكراد للهدف
نفسه يعني تقدر تقول حضرتك ان القوتين
الاقليميين بتتلاقى مصالحهم على هدف منع
وجود كيان كردي منفصل اه ولان هم كمان دي
عندها اكراد ودي عندها اقراض يعني يعني دي
تضرب فصائل معينه ودي تضرب فصائل اخرى ا
هي
فكره
مهاجمه الاكراد الذين يقدمون ماوى او دعم
او او ملجا لعناصر المعارضه سواء
تركيه طب دي قصه كبيره ومهمه استاذنك
نناقشها في وقت اني بس انت طرحت نقطه مهمه
جدا وخطيره ان ممكن تكون بعض النخب ترى في
الهجمات
اي تحليلك انا بقولش معلومه ما حك محلله
سياسيه ما انتش مسؤوله عراقيه ان ده ربما
يكون لا تخلو من بعض المزايا ومنها كبح
الطموحات الكرديه في الانفصال فا استاذنك
نناقشها في وقت تاني الحلقه السؤال الاخير
بقى كيف يمكن
ان تتاثر العراق في الا يع والشهور
المقبله بحرب غزه طيب
ا اولا هذا يتوقف على مسار الحرب مسار
مسار الصراع هل استمرار في
تصعيد
سقف يعني الاباده الجماعيه الى هذا الى ما
يفوق هذا المستوى اللي مش عارفه هيروح فين
يعني لكن هذا التصعيد الدموي الشديد ولا
لا لو افترضنا انه هيستمر هذا التصعيد في
عده سنار
اما ان تتصرف الولايات المتحده برشاد
وبالتالي تعود الى
قواعد الالتزام بقواعد الاشتباك انه اصابه
قواعدها او اصابه سفارتها لانه كمان تم
التعدي على السفاره ف تاخد اجراء محدود ما
يطل القيادات وما يطل اهداف بهذا الشكل ده
سيناريو وبالتالي نبقى في الاستيتس كو هو
استمرار الوضع على ما هو عليه الامر
الثاني انه الولايات المتحده لا تريد ان
ايصال رساله قويه لايران ومحور المقاومه
انه لن تتسامح في اي استهداف او في اي
اعتداء على مصالحها وبالتالي كل قصف من ا
فصائل الحشد لهداف خاصه بالولايات المتحده
هتقابل الولايات المتحده برد فعل اقوى
واعنف وهنا المساله تبقى مفتوحه على
مصراعيها وهذا يعجل بخروج المستشارين
العسكريين الامريكيين الحقيقه ده اقل اقل
الخسائر اللي ممكن تخسرها الولايات
المتحده لكن هي ممكن تراهن على علاقتها
بالعراق نفسه فيعني اتصور ان هم دول
السيناريوهين الاساسيين اما العوده الى
قواعد الاشتباك القديمه يعني اصابه مقابل
اصابه او يعني ضبط نفس او الثاني انه
انفلات الاوضاع وتحول الولايات المتحده من
كنها دخلت العراق من اجل يعني تغيير الوضع
واحلال الاستقرار الى انها تدخل
كطرف في طرف الصراع و مستهدفه مستهدفه من
العراقين من مسانده العراقيين وتحويله الى
نظام للديمقراطيه في الشرق الاوسط زي ما
كان بيتقال في وقت جورج بوش البل الى انها
هي اصبحت العدو لشعب العراقي اذا احنا
بنتكلم
على مدى تاثر العراق بالحرب هيتوقف على
مسار الحرب نفسه اذا الحرب وضعت اوزارها
وانتهت الح مسار الحرب ورد فعل الولايات
المتحده بس الاول ما هو مرد فعل الولايات
المتحده يبقى مرتبط بمسار الحرب نفترض
جدلا ان الحرب وضعت اوزارها غدا فالامور
هتهدا غالبا يعني اذا المساله اتسعت الحرب
استمرت او اتسعت فشملت مثلا حزب الله او
شملت عدوان على الحوثيين الى اخره ده وارد
يبقى ممكن الصراع يتسع وانت حرك بترج حي
ان هذا الاتساع هيظل داخل محصور ما بين
الحشد الشعبي والوجود الامريكي سواء في
العراق او في سوريا لكن بقى مع احتمال ان
احنا ما نتكلمش على فاصلين اثنين من الحشد
الجباء والكتائب لا بقى يضم عناصر اكبر
من من الحشد وربما ربما كمان التيار
الصدري يشتبك لان التيار الصدري من الاساس
هو كان ضد الوجود الامريكي يعني ربما
ينخرط بقو وفي هذه الحاله بقى سوف يتسع
الخرق على الراتق اه يبقى في يبقى اذا
اتسعت الحرب سوف تتسع المواجهه ما بين قوى
ا عراقيه معظمها من الواضح ان هو شيعي
بالدرجه الاولى يعني هؤلاء سوف يستهدفون
القوات الامريكيه واذا حدث ذلك سوف نكون
امام سن روهين اما قواعد الاشتباك الكلمه
اللي بقت يعني ك كل حاجه قواعد اشتباك
اضرب لك في حته فراغ تضرب لي في حته
مهجوره وهكذا اشتباك منضبط او تنفلت
الاوضاع اذا الولايات المتحده ردت بقوه
على كل هجوم تتعرض له لان هي تتعرض الى
هجمات متعدده كرد فعل لما يجري على
الاراضي هذا ما تتوقعيه مع الدكتوره مش
كده بال جزيل الشكر مع الدكتوره شكرا انا
اللي سعيده وشكرا لاستضافتك يا استاذ ربنا
يخليكي تشرفنا بيكي شكرا جزيلا لحضراتكم
ونلقاكم في حلقات اخرى ان شاء الله مع
استاذتنا الدكتوره نفين مسعد استاذ
العلوم استاذ النظم السياسيه والمحلله
السياسيه البارزه شكرا جزيلا